all right how do i open the overlay in
[ __ ]
shift f2 okay there we go yeah alt f4
[Music]
i hate you hey look all our pictures are
there yeah yeah
really into bob's middle fingers you
just have to believe what the [ __ ]
swaggy not barbara oh god i don't know
whose swag he is and i don't care no
swaggy can't be that bad swaggy could be
that bad i don't i don't think you
understand how
why are you barbara why'd you do that i
had a movie i literally i literally had
nothing else i could do you had nothing
i don't know if you wanted me i want a
little bit of fairness i just want a
little bit a little bit of fairness and
why'd you do that mark why did you
change because i was this is what i
wanted in the first place
[Laughter]
[Music]
wait dial it back we're playing noodle
for like nine hours today okay you need
to calm down yeah you gotta pace
yourself if this is happening go that
high for nine hours on the game all
right so this game uh god damn it it was
my turn oh [ __ ] uh whoever wins everyone
else has to gift 50 subs to that person
right that's how this works i don't i
can't that's my birthday so i'm excited
150 bucks wouldn't it be 250 no it would
be fun oh lord oh [ __ ] yes
one gift
from me yeah uh i will gift one of the
numbers in that number i will gift that
amount of subs oh boy okay wait
here buddy this for you
all right thanks man why did you have
this many sevens
yellow no
oh wait no hang on wait no that doesn't
have yellow anyone went jumping
no balls
man i appreciate the i see
wait mark i had to play i don't care oh
boy oh no yeah oh that's not so good
it's definitely not yellow make it
yellow to punish me yeah okay uh-huh oh
daddy
i can do this
[Laughter]
get in here what are you doing well
come on
i can't believe it actually was yellow
red red yes red red red bread well now
i'm not gonna do it what if he has
yellow
well i mean he's not gonna go i was
gonna go to you but i'm not gonna give
it
what's your problem what's your problem
man we just started wait yeah what is
that oh it tells us what it is that does
it says
yay
wait i nee i just need a promise from
you that you're just gonna you're gonna
hold it together and you're just gonna
really like try it
try to be the man that we all know you
can be it's your birthday tomorrow you
need to really
yeah okay
you really what about that oh come on
oh funny oh what the [ __ ]
oh swaggy oh [ __ ] me coming in hot with
the barbara
what's up
where barbara's got her own [ __ ]
alternate identity god damn it all right
what are you going to do there almost
immediately right back please
i'm asking you as a friend wow well when
you say it like that how can i not oh
thank you thank you i appreciate that
man wait a minute
[Laughter]
seriously just fully
[Laughter]
i yes like well tomorrow is my birthday
and swaggy just [ __ ] me baby oh my god
well okay here's a big [ __ ] you from me
to you then friend challenge him
challenge him he can't possibly be there
no i know what he has no you don't know
what he had what are you talking about
just so that there's not two uno hands
i'm gonna challenge
i i knew we didn't have any yellows all
right okay all right okay all right guys
who are henry jimmy and tommy is that a
thing is that a reference to something
yeah you don't know them oh no
wait hang on gta role play marcus henry
bob is jimmy wade is tommy
who what
i don't know who these are god why
who is that
why am i what
swaggy
[ __ ] you
i really tried to
i did not put my dick in your ass i want
to be very clear right
was like lighting right into the dm's i
didn't dig with yours no that's a lie i
didn't do that you dick whipped his pee
pee and then you put it in my boob i put
it in your boob
i just want to be clear what the hell
you're talking about hang on wait
[ __ ] you're swaggy eat my blue
[ __ ] you could have said balls
suck this bob eat my blue
baskets
yeah normally mark would have owed me 50
gifted subs there but dude i can't
afford to do it do you want me to do you
want
so like let's both no it's both
we're good we are all good we could low
stakes this what if you just go on a
sweet winning streak
oh [ __ ] even one loss would make me go
broke
how
henry jimmy and tom tama tama tom what
the hell happened to me tommy are from
goodfellas oh okay
why swaggy why are things okay over
there wait are you
do you need help put jimmy pot pie thank
you oh i'm not muted shut up
[Laughter]
wait who hurt you what's wrong
shut up is it weird to say pot pie pie i
just like saying it like that yeah yeah
it's fine man
that's a little weird that's not the
part i'm laughing
it's just papaya you know yeah yeah papa
papaya
may we go to the park
today my nightbot keep saying i'm dad
nightbot what the [ __ ] happened to you
who did this to my nightbot i don't know
man i'm just gonna keep it i'm just
gonna keep doing this until i no no blue
not blue not blue
give me another one yes perfect oh i
can't jump in on that
every
[ __ ]
mother
oh
jimmy
wow we got to get rid of one card that's
a great uh great devotee
thank you bob you say you're kidding me
bob are you you saved me bob i'm
[ __ ] me right now my god damn i
saved you mark i did that for you man
thank you
oh my god i'm not trying to be mean to
you wait i'm trying to be nice to you
okay
i feel like you know this is one of
those things wait where you're setting
yourself up for failure because i have
none of the blue i got one blue now who
me oh i forgot about the rule oh [ __ ]
yeah all right
it's okay man just it's just uno you
just gotta get it you're just gonna take
a deep breath no fine no
no
i don't believe you
no ah [ __ ] a dick that's okay i just
wanted to see your cards it's a strategy
that means a good dick oh that's the
wrong word
you two yellows have you made a blue you
can suck my [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
why would you want that wade i had 11
cards
okay bob what is the sand i don't like
this hand it's not good i was trying to
get rid of it for a long time and i
couldn't [ __ ] do anything about it
not good not good
yes [ __ ] you swaggy give me your hand oh
wait okay in hindsight i realized i made
a mistake
why am i getting so many gifted subs i
know we don't we don't talk about this
now but why the [ __ ] am i getting so
many gifted subs what because any time
you talk about gifted subs everyone's
like oh yeah it's your birthday mark you
ordered it buddy but wade's the one
that's starving about to lose his house
why are people giving beats
i'm about to lose my house
with the throwing little plus twos at me
there
why do you no please god my god
god why god it's not god it's swaggy
why
i swear to god swagging is just
reskinned the barber i don't know what
this does i mean it's like all bots in
this game are programmed the same or
something you know we have a random card
that's right you just never realized
that you know things could get worse
than barbara you just didn't realize how
good you had it oh megan you again never
oh we again still you take my goddamn
turn there we go weirdo i gave you
another turn i don't know what you're
moaning about oh sexy carrick here you
wait go again oh
got him good one
can i have a turn
can i have a turn can i
no mark
i'm trying to be chill okay i'm trying
to include wade okay you know what i'm
saying
oh [ __ ] all right calm down it's okay
can you can i [ __ ] can i play can i
play the game
i never remind you
cool cool you got it too
i got this
dokie
you got any greens mark
no
d
no yeah you'd eat it oh
god oh my god still no i don't know
there we go you'll draw some greens man
green green green you want green you
want green no
you don't get green
yeah yeah try me
i don't know
swaggy is crazy i think hey but you
don't give a [ __ ] man oh yes
huh
no no no swaggy be nice i could be good
so i could be gentle what is that
my cards what does that do why does that
do that
oh
oh dear swaggy what the [ __ ] is that
wait listen
okay bob we're gonna play a little game
[Music]
wait wait wait wait i don't like this
game okay well hold on here
[Laughter]
okay oh boy nice card
all right cool i like this game
swaggy has a winner oh boy oh boy why am
i skipped again oh why am i skipped
again awesome cards swagger this game
mark what color do you think hey
i don't remember
is it yellow
it is yellow
[Applause]
[Laughter]
why are people giving me subs give them
to wade
he can't afford like a bag of turnips he
he's he's like desperate [ __ ] would i
buy a bag of turnips for turnip soup
wade's sound material is actually
mounted on recycled cardboard that he
got from the grocery store he he's
actually streaming from an open field
that just looks like he's in a room
he's desperately in need he's using the
green leaves in the background as a
green screen
he's so sad please from his dark cold
hotel room
help him he is broke as [ __ ]
i have a four
bar
i don't like you very much
he gave you a four and you just get this
unbridled quiet monopoly-esque hate
towards him what does that do again
green
[Laughter]
um [ __ ] it man you got a lot of weird
stuff in there whoo i got a lot of weird
stuff in me now too all right i [ __ ]
want turnips god damn it it's for people
to be [ __ ]
for the turnips please
chad everyone's [ __ ] trying to give
me a buy turn i don't even know what
that turn up tastes like oh god why do
you guys love blue so much what is with
you in blue i don't love blue okay no it
could be me bob it could have been my
torn torn could have been my thorn are
you what oh my god again i guess hey
mark listen how about green how about
yellow
all right i'll take it i'll take it oh
how about red i guess geez
here bob do you know you want mine oh
you know you want mine oh yeah um i
guess the obvious oh yeah yeah
yeah oh wait no okay all right
oh yeah yeah you know you know you want
me
the one who you know
yeah okay
you know you want mine you played
you think i'm played
don't swaggy
swaggy uh
wait you gonna have a lot of cards
if someone says here's some bits for the
two decades you're about to leave behind
does that mean i'm gonna die or does
that mean
oh you're so dead yeah definitely
that was
mark what the [ __ ] is this oh you're
complaining oh wait really wait wait
hang on you're complaining waiting yes
you're
[Music]
oh boy
all right that's better that's not good
at all
nothing about this is better it's better
it's better all right well [ __ ] whatever
that does [ __ ] you guys
all right does that one all right all
right how many turnips are you gonna buy
after this wade uh i don't know how much
a goddamn turnip cost but probably none
why would i buy turnips yeah yeah you
want mine can't i buy like spaghettios
or chicken soup or something you won't
why no turnips are like a cost-effective
way you can make turnip soup you can
like if you get what is the broth water
the turnips water turnips in water
obviously
you stupid idiot i
ah
i mean listen man times are tough but
they're not like turnip water tough
like my mom my mom makes a great turnip
soup it is delicious
if it's just turnips and water how can
it be any different than any other
turnips have you ever eaten a turnip man
it's no it's a it's a food it's food i
have not been abundantly clear i've
never had a [ __ ] turnip i guess i
shouldn't be surprised you you your food
expertise is so
unbelievably
unbelievably non-existent
oh okay all right tell me the most
diverse food you've eaten what's the
strangest food you've ever eaten
strangest yeah what's the strangest food
uh does like eating raw ants and stuff
in the wild count no no like an actual
food that you could get at a restaurant
oh probably like a squid or a gator or
something nothing that crazy okay i
guess that's all right oh well we're
starting this one off with a bang bang
bang
what am i doing i just clicked things i
don't know what i'm doing i just
couldn't wait where someone offered to
let me just stay with them when i
inevitably lose my thumbs in chat so i
stopped paying attention to anything
i guess i'm losing my house everybody i
at least have a place to stay
take this swaggy wade needs turnips okay
i don't know if you're not listening
i still get the [ __ ] wrong bags of
doritos in my p.o box please do not have
to give me [ __ ]
doritos as you can find yeah yeah yeah
no we're going to start a petition
doritos is going to make turnip flavor
for wade
for his needs
oh damn oh hot damn i'll wait
what color does swaggy have win
what green i made it green for myself
what
what what what what one of it it's not
great what's going on yes fix it fix it
all right
wait but mark has maybe green as long as
it's not swaggy it's it's all right it's
all good
oh numbers only oh god okay well
absolutely
farmer's only cousins only are we going
back down no no no no no no no no
oh god oh god oh god
oh there we go that's mark thanks man oh
man thanks for doing that thank you oh
another one
what the [ __ ] just
hey
yeah
all right
hey guess what this hand still doesn't
have [ __ ] blue it's okay wait if it
makes you feel any better i don't have
blue either does that make you feel any
better
no no bob no not like i'm sorry i just
did it i had no choice
it's not my fault there's nothing i
could do about it okay
it's beyond it's out of my it's beyond
my reckoning and out of my control not
your reckoning no that's it lies beyond
my ken no oh it's me
i'm really sorry bud
uh well that was kind of a level someone
just subbed the turnip soup so now the
turnip soup is a sub
[Laughter]
thank you for that wait you're gonna
have to make a video after this of you
actually cooking and eating turnip soup
you have to please do it i know how much
you like turnip soup win we all
wait hang on listen that's not what you
want
[Laughter]
damn it we all know wade we all
understand
darn it ah jeez why do we play this game
why is it green i hate oh no
no why why again why
what have i done to you
what did i do
it's not my fault it's clearly your
fault i didn't do it thank you you saved
me good sir i didn't do it look it was
it was
i couldn't touch him
you know how it is we can't touch
can i buy ice cream
turnips ice cream what no someone said i
could buy ice cream cake instead of
turnips what does that mean no that one
why would that even be a thing no you
get birthday turnips we stick a candle
in a turnip we light it on fire you blow
it out you eat the tournament that's
your birthday wait wait
someone in chat my chat just said wait
is to turn up as bob is to lobster
what does that mean
is there something i don't understand
about my relationship with lobster sorry
mark i don't know why are you sorry
what oh uh mark i believe has blue so
let's not let mark win
yeah he's got blue it's a lie don't
believe him it's a lie hmm
sexy carrot
sexy weird al oh this is actually weird
l anyway i think he actually has yellow
so i think
turn up sounds [ __ ] horrible god damn
it ice cream turnip you've never had a
turnip it's it's it's actually good like
i wouldn't bite into it raw but there's
good silicon
i couldn't not do anything couldn't do
it green
no sorry
yellow
yep no not oh mark's not oh
i think we're good yeah i'm not at risk
anymore i don't you know my my time
close to the sun my wings melted no
no
god why
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ] i had two cards
you're getting a lot better use out of
your go xlr than i am
dude you just gotta get some funny [ __ ]
loaded on there and then push it right
and it's beautiful
it doesn't have to mean anything you
just just clip whatever just no no no
yay
[Laughter]
god damn it oh boy
i hate you oh boy listen wait i'm gonna
save your turn for you okay turn nipple
crust turnip crust oh jesus christ
that's the worst used i've ever in my
life and people are so fast at just
making a bunch of new accounts for
whatever random [ __ ] we talk about
it's also it's french it's turnip le
crust i don't know why you're calling it
turn nipple crust that's just weird
all right well what the okay [ __ ] you
you wade you [ __ ] you're listening to
gifted subs you're thinking about
turnips oh dude i was so ready to [ __ ]
you
guys i'm so prepared to sex you
god what the [ __ ] oh my god no why
why haven't you done this what what
could you possibly have gained from this
wait this didn't help anyone why did you
do this it's not like that no no why
have you done this funky bunch why are
you doing this
i like how the the rage and discussion
comes at huge waves i think i think it's
just because wade is is breaking the
rules
rules of the podcast and and addressing
his subs which was the rules we're not
allowed to do that we're not doing the
podcast we're playing a goddamn game
right that's all the podcast what is
this is that podcast this is games no
it's what the [ __ ] [ __ ] you want me to
read all my turnip puns out loud no i
don't want you to read them at all
ignore them
whipsonly.com thank you for the five
dollars no you have to ignore them
turnipcousins.com
just the tips
anything else you guys want from me keep
going keep going draw some [ __ ] cards
because [ __ ] me oh
[Music]
i'll be your hype guy i got you so bob
how are you you're doing good i'm good
you know i'm good i'm feeling good good
good good man good man yeah oh yeah poor
swaggy oh dear it's blue now why do you
two have so many cards
excuse me
[ __ ] excuse me mr not paying
attention to the game donation man
swaggy why are you such a piece of [ __ ]
all right wait what color do you want we
can give you wait please stop your
amazing commentary for two seconds to
pick a color
i had one of those too
it's okay maggie doesn't give a [ __ ]
about what color we want it to be
we've got a system going on we got a
good we got a good [ __ ] oh your life is
so hard
all your
so many turnips out there yeah yeah yeah
wait hey listen
don't do that
i realized my mistake
that moment the markiplier done realized
he [ __ ] up
i don't know i don't even know what
color he has is it red it's red anymore
ah well there you go
[Laughter]
maybe it's this color god bob you're
gonna put you're gonna
[Laughter]
yes yes yes
my hand are you sure you don't want what
well whatever no i like this end shut up
it's it's good okay
no it's fine it was it was a good call
to not take this hand well this is
becoming
increasingly unwinnable don't worry
guys just let me get to my turn just let
me get to my turn
as normal i'll fix it i'll fix it
i fixed it okay
oh my god how are these the two that i
got left with
my life it's all good it's all good it's
[ __ ] better
oh come on oh well all right that's oh
oh no what the [ __ ] happened
[ __ ] me
this is so fun
some of those weren't swears
[Laughter]
all right you're not getting me this
time you're not getting me this time sir
okay
all right you okay
i once was does it help you mark no
oh i guess it doesn't matter anyway
oh oh did you guys click on the game i
clicked it
okay so you guys you guys are so slow
when it's swaggy but when i'm doing it
you have bullet-like reflexes i see how
it is guys
both of you when it's not me just like
oh god i knocked my monitor overall i
can't figure out how to do this oh god
what's going on here
all right wait all right all right it's
coming back to you wait it's fine it's
fine
oh
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh my god that's not a good color
[Applause]
oh thanks bud you're welcome bud i
appreciate that i appreciate that
no i don't does anyone know what color
swagger i have no idea let's just draw
and see what we get then what's harder
the card okay i guess they get a 5.
okay well that was short-lived
you know what mark i this is actually
something you want to happen all right
all right let's see what uh this dude
okay all right all right this to me and
we do we okay let's do we let's we do
let's do come
[Music]
[Laughter]
what are you doing here what are you
doing no don't do it no no no not like
this
no not like this
no yellow no yellow bob
nice oh i could have 69 it but it's the
wrong color what does that even mean
what does it mean you could have 69 it
wasn't what do you think it means right
i don't even know what we all know what
that means no i don't know what that
means what does that mean you [ __ ]
dare
you kick it
you know okay
i didn't know you didn't want me to win
that badly swaggy
[Laughter]
swaggy is on my team shut up
oh thanks dude i have some of those
yeah keep it yellow that's what i want
please keep it wave you know what card i
have
[Music]
you